AND DR. PHIL ANALYZES THE
WHITE HOUSE, WHAT?
WHILE THE MEDIA ASSAILS THE
PRESIDENT, IT'S ALL IN OUR
UNSEEN END SCENE SEGMENTS.
BUT FIRST, READING, WRITING AND
ACTIVISM.
OUR COLLEGIATE INDOCTRINATION
FACTORIES.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WATCHING HOW THINGS HAVE PLAYED
OUT DURING THE FIRST 13 MONTHS
OF THE TRUMP ERA, I'VE COME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT LIBERALS
JUST AREN'T THAT INTERESTED IN
ADVOCATING POLICIES THAT IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF AMERICANS.
BUT WHAT THEY DO WANT, AND PART
OF THE OBAMA LEGACY IS A
CONSTANT STATE OF PROTEST AND
AGITATION.
A RESISTANCE FORCE FED TO THEM
IN THEIR HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
YEARS AND NOW PROFESSORS
THEMSELVES ARE NURTURING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF
REVOLUTIONARIES.
AT MANY COLLEGES, STUDENTS ARE
NOW EXPECTED TO SKIP CLASS TO
ATTEND SOCIAL JUSTICE RALLIES.
CASE AND POINT, ON YALE'S
ADMISSIONS LOCK UNDER THE TITLE
IN SUPPORT OF STUDENT PROTESTS,
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
ADMISSIONS RIGHTS FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO COME TO YELL, WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE FIRST IN
ISSUES OF SOCIAL JUSTICE.
ACCORDING TO WALTER OLSON AND
YOUR "WALL STREET JOURNAL," YALE
DOES NOT COUNT SKIPPING CLASSES
FOR PROTESTS LIKE WE'VE SEEN
LATELY AGAINST THE APPLICANT.
NO PROBLEM WHATSOEVER.
CHECK THIS OUT, THE DEAN OF
ADMISSIONS AT TUFTS UNIVERSITY,
HER NAME IS KAREN RICHARDSON,
AFTER THE PARK WHEN SHOOTING
ISSUED THE STATEMENT TO
APPLICANTS.
SHE SAID I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT TUFTS IS A PLACE WHERE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS NOT ONLY
TOLERATED, IT'S ENCOURAGED
STRONGLY.
SO WHEN YOU ACT ON YOUR VALUES
IN A PRINCIPLED WAY ON ISSUES
ABOUT WHICH YOU FEEL
PASSIONATELY, IT WILL NOT BE
HELD AGAINST YOU IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
IN FACT, WE MAY EVEN TAKE NOTICE
IN FACT, WE MAY EVEN TAKE NOTIC
NOTICE.
FORGET VOLUNTEERING WITH THE
ELDERLY OR HELPING SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILDREN, PUT THAT ON YOUR
COLLEGE APPLICATION.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO GET INTO
THAT COLLEGE OF YOUR CHOICE, GO
YELL AT A CONSERVATIVE SENATOR
AND THEN POSTED ON YOUTUBE.
THERE ARE OTHER UNIVERSITIES
ALSO STOKING ACTIVISM OUT THERE.
AT VALDOSTA STATE IN GEORGIA,
THE WOMEN'S AND GENDERS READY
DEPARTMENT ENCOURAGES STUDENTS
IN THEIR DIVISION TO ORGANIZE
AND IMPLEMENT ANNUAL SOCIAL
JUSTICE EVENTS SUCH AS THE
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
AWARENESS MONTH, AND THE
PRODUCTION OF THE VAGINA
MONOLOGUES AND NATIONAL COMING
OUT DAY.
BUT POLITICALLY PERHAPS I HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
STUDENT ORGANIZING LIKE
BARACK OBAMA.
LAST YEAR HE TALKED ABOUT
TRAINING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZERS.
>> I AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN CREATE
AN EFFECTIVE NETWORK OF GLOBAL
ACTIVISTS, SOME WHO ARE IN
POLITICS, SOME WHO ARE IN
BUSINESS, SOME WHO ARE IN
JOURNALISM OR WORKING FOR NGOS.
AND PROVIDE THEM THE TOOLS, THE
TRAINING, THE NETWORKS, THE
RELATIONSHIPS, THE FUNDING SO
THAT THEY CAN BE EVEN MORE
EFFECTIVE.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE TRAINING LIKE
COLD WRITERS TO WORK IN THE
21ST CENTURY ECONOMY, BUT WE ARE
TRAINING THE ACTIVISTS.
I WOULD SAY ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID THERE, THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN PRETTY EFFECTIVE,
POLICING SPEECH CODES ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, EJECTING
ADMINISTRATORS WHO DON'T TOE
THEIR POLITICAL LINE AND NOW
PUSHING FOR DACA AND GUN CONTROL
LAWS.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING INSIDIOUS
AFOOT HERE.
A FEW YEARS AGO THE HEAD OF A
YALE COLLEGE WAS FORCED TO
RESIGN AFTER HIS WIFE, ALSO A
PROFESSOR, DARED TO SEND OUT A
MASS EMAIL OBJECTING TO YALE'S
HALLOWEEN COSTUME RULES.
SHE SUGGESTED MERELY THAT YALE
STUDENTS BE ALLOWED TO WEAR
WHATEVER THEY WANT AS A COSTUME,
KIND OF PRO-CHOICE.
EVEN OF NOXIOUS OR OFFENSIVE
COSTUMES.
THE PROTEST CROWD CORNER HER ON
THE
QUAD.
HE TRIED TO HAVE AN ACTUAL
DISCUSSION WITH THEM.
>> WE ARE SITTING HERE TELLING
YOU THAT YOU'RE BEING RACIST.
>> EMPATHY IS NOT NECESSARY FOR
YOU TO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE
WRONG.
>> LET US TELL YOU YOU ARE BEING
RACIST.
>> OH, NO, .
I DISAGREE.
>> IT'S NOT A DEBATE!
>> LOOK AT ME.
LOOK AT ME.
>> LOOK AT ME AND MY FACE FIRST
OF ALL.
>> YOU NEVER TRY TO KNOW WHO I
AM.
>> DO NOT INTERRUPT ME.
>> YOU WAIT UNTIL IT IS YOUR
TURN.
>> JUST LOOK AT HER.
>> YOU ARE DISGUSTING!
>> Laura: THIS IS NOT A
DEBATE, DID YOU HEAR THAT?
AT LEAST THEY ADMIT IT NOW.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
DEBATE.
THEY WOULD RATHER GRANDSTAND AND
BULLY AND HURL INSULTS THAN
ACTUALLY MAKE A COGENT ARGUMENT.
IS IT ANY WONDER WHY A KNIGHT
FOUNDATION SURVEY FOUND THAT 54%
OF COLLEGE STUDENTS SAY THE
CLIMATE ON CAMPUS STIFLES THEIR
EXPRESSION FOR FEAR OF OFFENDING
OTHERS?
THE INDOCTRINATION OF THESE
STUDENTS BEGINS EARLIER AND
EARLIER.
I'M TALKING GRAMMAR AND MIDDLE
SCHOOL, AND ONCE REPROGRAMMED,
LIBERAL ADULTS DEPLOY THE
STUDENT BOTS TO DO THEIR OWN
POLITICAL BIDDING.
JUST LOOK AT THE WAY THEY'VE
USED THE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
PARKLAND.
CERTAIN STONEMAN DOUGLAS STUDENT
SUCCESSFULLY DID USE THEIR
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO SPREAD
THEIR ANTI-GUN DEMANDS, NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
BUT LET'S PULL BACK THE CURTAIN
HERE.
GROUPS LIKE EVERY TOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY, FOUNDED BY BILLIONAIRE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG GAVE
$2.5 MILLION TO SUPPORT HUNDREDS
OF MARCHES FOR GUN CONTROL,
INCLUDING THE BIG ONE LATER THIS
MONTH.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS TELLING
US THAT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
THE ST. LOUIS AREA ARE NOT ONLY
PLANNING A WALK OUT ON APRIL,
BUT THEY ARE PLANNING A PROTEST
AT THE OFFICE OF REPUBLICAN
MISSOURI ATTORNEY GENERAL JOSH
HOLLY, WHO WANTS TO UNSEAT
DEMOCRAT SENATOR CLAIRE
McCASKILL.
AGAIN, THE GOAL HERE IS
POLITICAL POWER.
THE IDEA THAT THIS IS MERELY A
STUDENT-LIKE, TOTALLY TOTALLY
ORGANIC ALTRUISTIC CRUSADE TO
END GUN VIOLENCE IS DECEIVING.
YOU ARE NOT LOOKING AT IT
CAREFULLY ENOUGH.
THE FOCUS HERE REALLY IS POWER
AND ITS PARTISAN.
MARCH ON THE NEAREST
CONSERVATIVE, TAKE DOWN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ADVOCACY GROUPS LIKE
THE NRA, YOU BET.
DON'T FALL FOR ALL THE FRESH
YOUNG FACES YOU SEE RECITING THE
LIBERAL TROPES.
THE STUDENT PROTESTERS ARE
AMPLIFIED, SUPPORTED AND FUNDED
BY OLD GUARD LIBERALS.
HOLLYWOOD ELITES LIKE GEORGE
CLOONEY AND OPRAH.
BUSINESS ELITES LIKE MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG AND THE MEDIA VANGUARD
AT PLACES LIKE NBC AND OF COURSE
CNN.
SO WITHOUT ALL OF THAT SUPPORT,
OF COURSE THEY WOULDN'T BE
RECEIVING THIS ATTENTION.
MAYBE THEY WOULD EVEN BE BACK AT
SCHOOL LEARNING SOMETHING.
BUT WHEN YOU CAN GET COLLEGE
CREDIT, OR MAYBE EVEN A FAST
PASS TO THE IVY LEAGUE BY
PROTESTING, WHY STUDY?
HANGING OUT WITH BILL MAHER AND